happy and seven day my name is Jake and
I'm here with John Luke if you haven't
noticed by now there is a new mass
effect trailer in fact there are a
couple new mass effect trailers but
we're gonna break down the story one
that was revealed earlier today so let's
get into this yeah so I'm gonna stop you
right at the first frame here so we can
just kind of set the stage for what's
going on what we saw from the other end
ramat initiative trailers that there are
three arcs that have been sent to the
Andromeda galaxy in order to find new
planets based on the trailer it sounds
like of the three each kind of focuses
on a different race there's one of human
and then from there may be one soleran
because we do see silurian later the
trailer and then sorry probably but
terrines are also supposed to be in this
game so well there's also really sure is
also a fourth ship thing it's like way
bigger than the others and that in that
other trailer the head of the
initiatives said that she and everyone
else will be on that one so that could
be me be like and then a mix of other
people could just be on that and this
one in particular this human one do we
know is called Hyperion but as you can
see so even though this is probably
Hyperion the human one there are sorry
on it as well yep and this up the
timeline they it's supposed to take
place six hundred years later like
everyone goes into cryostasis and wakes
up six hundred dudes later outside of
the Andromeda galaxy in the website they
say that it takes place in 2185 that
actually is during Mass Effect 2 mass
spec to takes place during that time and
mass effect 3 takes place in 86 so this
implies that they did all this before
the Reapers came and started the whole
Reaper war in Mass Effect 3 which is
interesting and I wonder if that is
actually maybe the motivation for why
this is happening and then here we see a
character flying out of the airlock it
looks like yeah we're pretty sure its
rider yeah the white suit seems to be
righter so there he is again yep and one
thing I noticed is the aesthetics of
this helmet like the glowing yellow eyes
kind of reminds me of the Cerberus
helmets from three I don't know if
that's maybe just a coincidence the
right because also in that timeline it
said that the this initiative was
privately funded yeah and Cerberus
probably I'm sure had a hand in that and
I would make but whether or not that
would affect the mask is probably we're
looking a little too much into it
alright so here we got Ryder that's a
beautiful shot of oh yeah I'm not a fan
of the look of
the male rider character you can change
him obviously search the generic look
I'm not into but this planet looks
stunning and then here we also see the
logo for the Andromeda initiative and
that's the tempest right there yep not
really it's the only time they show it
really any realer seems pretty likely
that you will be flying that based on
the other two they released in of course
dozens of leaks all right this right
here is probably the bridge for the
tempest I'd say so I mean it looks a lot
like the one that was shown in the e3
2015 trailer yep and then right here
looks like we have a new species of some
sort some people in the officer saying
on could be for sure it could be tarian
but i don't think so i don't think you
think so either i think this is
definitely a new species and if you
notice on the neck their skin seems to
be merging with their armor which
implies some sort of like cybernetic
enhancements merging of like technology
similar to like how the collectors kind
of were in mass effect 2 okay so here we
got our four characters that kind of
show throughout the trailer one of
them's rider one of them is female rider
which would be the other character you
get to play as one of them is the asari
and we have a fourth male human you kind
of brought up the idea that this maybe
could have four player yeah so I was
thinking since this time there whether
you pick male or female rider the other
one is still going to be with you so I
was thinking maybe pretty much all the
missions you know it's right or mail
right or female and then you pick your
through squad made something for a total
of four I'm not sold on this because
there's some other shots later they
clearly show there's only three people
in a squad and I want to float an idea
by you on the specs for the collectors
edition it mentions 12 four-player
multiplayer Oh actually this is that
referring to a mass effect 3 style
multiplayer or is that referring to a
cooperative multiplayer I mean sing for
their would make sense for a cooperative
multiplayer but know if I'd want that I
don't want that either I would
definitely not do that that is would be
interesting what multiplayer will do
this is obviously all speculation but I
think there will be certain missions
that you can do cooperatively how
interesting yeah yeah yeah that would be
my guess I don't know a lot of stuff to
break down in this one let's get the big
one out of the way that kind of looks
like maybe a Leviathan from aspect 3
which
the species that the Reapers are based
on its kind of my theory I personally I
I hope it's not a Reaper I don't think
it's a Reaper but you do bring up some
good points and I know you don't want it
to be a Reaper I there no no i don't but
there are some striking similarities
with that another thing to know is the
tempest machine gun on the guys thigh on
the right reoccurring gun for mass
effect two and three in the middle a
rider has a modified version of the m6
which is the iconic Mass Effect rifle in
the arc breakdown trailer they show like
a bunch of weapons and they showed the
karna fix but they also showed what
looked like a different version of the
MC actually did not label it so I wasn't
entirely sure what was but I'm like that
kind of looks like the m6 but like
different and then you also notice
something else in this which is almost a
little easter egg I'd say yeah they have
a this exploding canister here is a the
exact same model from two and three
which you would shoot in combat there's
not a whole lot to say about this shot
other than the fact that it just shows
that the cutscenes this time around have
a lot more range to them like there's so
much more animation detail and you see
male and female riders together at sort
of a maybe heartwarming or touching
scene although she looks injured all
right right here we have the same alien
that we saw before and some sort of new
weapon on the right you can kinda see
sort of the face but they're doing a
pretty good job blurring it like they
they seem to want to keep the reveal of
these creatures hidden and we think this
is probably the same type of alien from
earlier yeah yeah and here's where
things get interesting yeah okay so we
got this n7 guy who's been in all the
promotional material for the game but by
our said is not rider and it's clearly a
different person because later on we see
them with somebody who's probably writer
and as in writer the main character as
in writer the main character and that's
why I want to bring up because on the
box it shows the n7 guy and on his
helmet is sketched the word rider it's
like carved into it on the side so you
have two theories just have two
different theories so the and the second
theory can actually still work with the
first theory though so the first theory
is that this is riders dad and that is
something they have brought up before
right that the voice over in the
Andromeda initiative teaser was writers
and the opening of this teaser as well
in the opening of this teaser
so then leaning into that is my theory
is that they they are the Pathfinder
they mention how each arc has a
pathfinder who is a person of like
significance you know like a combination
of a soldier scientist and that writer
becomes the new path finder which makes
sense for kind of that gives your
character the leeway to sort of explore
and that they are the old Pathfinder and
maybe they die and that you take their
place and maybe take their armor you
have to get the summer at some point in
this yeah like it is such an iconic
armor there is no way you will not wear
the n7 armor at some point I think that
is his dad I don't think he dies though
it was not right away like I don't think
he died at the beginning and then you
get or you become Pathfinder I think
they're gonna let that right out a
little bit so right here we see them in
the background that is probably riders
it's got the same armor and they're
doing something this is clearly a maybe
not the same area but a similar type of
area as we saw in that PlayStation yeah
it looks very familiar to that and then
the so I don't know what these are d I
don't know they look like they could be
Corrine or something like that although
I don't think that's it I don't know I
think it's a new race I don't think it's
one we've seen so far in this trailer I
think it's just a new a new race I agree
and then yeah I think it looks like a
reaper I hate to say it I think it looks
like a Reaper but I don't think it is a
Reaper maybe it's just me holding on
holding on haha I really don't want to
be a Reaper ok so this this is important
i think this is one of the coolest shots
of the trailer because this looks like
gameplay yep and not only does the flag
gameplay but this looks like wild game
play like look at the scope of his thing
yeah that is insane we are kind of
speculating on what this thing is you
brought up like horizon zero dawn sort
of like it's it's almost like yeah
technological wild creature maybe yeah
I'm curious if it's sentient or if it's
controlled by someone or if it's just
like you landed on a planet you stumbled
across this I doubt that hmm you met on
the box it also or only leaked box that
says destructible environments right so
it could be kind of cool to see this
thing just wreck town like through who
totally through planets yeah
then you're also holding two different
weapons that we haven't seen before that
look like alien new alien weapons as
well which is cool and then here we go
this is kind of back where we had three
squad members that's why I'm not sold on
having four here it looks like male
right or female writer and the other
character I mean it's entirely possible
just the saris just add a frame could be
that to ya so this here is also clearly
in game as well as as far as it looks
like you're playing it you're being
attacked by some sort of drone similar
to what we saw in the PlayStation
trailer and then right here these are
Larry Solarians so first Solarians
citing I think this is like other than a
sorry this is like the first sighting of
an alien from totally we have seen
Krogan in someone like the tech demo
yeah all right and then we got this guy
here who's clearly the antagonist is
kind of my theory we were sort of saying
he they seem to be going for more of a
sarin vibe is kind of what I'm getting
off of this guy sort of a singular
antagonist that you will be facing yeah
and I also think this is a different
kind of alien too because if you looked
at the one before who we saw his back
you didn't see this sort of ring thing
around his head yeah I don't know maybe
it just could be a different variation
of the same alien but I kind of don't
think so i think this is this is your
villain and he's going to be very
different yep and that is the trailer
and then they mentioned that they're
going to show the first gameplay reveal
at the game awards 2016 so that is the
Mass Effect Andromeda trailer if there's
anything you noticed that we missed let
us know in the comments below or you can
find us on Twitter and for more on Mass
Effect stay tuned to gamespot
you